what's going on with risk aversion and
men not approaching women sure so risk
aversion refers to a personality trait
or disposition where individuals are
basically more accepting or more willing
to take risks so highrisk aversion would
be individuals who are uh less willing
to take risks and a big risk for men at
least a perceived risk is of course
approaching women so recently I
conducted a survey and I used a measure
of risk aversion and I asked about
approach Behavior basically approaching
for dates approaching on the Street
approaching in a bar talking to someone
at work or in class and yeah there's an
inverse correlation or I should say a
positive correlation with that risk
aversion and willingness to approach
right that people who are more risk
averse much less willing to approach
they tend to have more fears as well as
far as the potential consequences of of
approaching a woman asking for a date
what did they say were the primary fears
that these guys were concerned about
sure so some of the primary fears are
basically social rejection and social
consequ quences there were some
differences where individuals higher in
risk aversion might fear more legal
consequences as well like uh some kind
of report to HR the police or even
something like that but it tends to be
mostly kind of a fear of like loss of of
reputation yeah well I suppose you know
we have a basis for this ancestrally
that if you were rebuffed by one of the
women in your tribe that that probably
wouldn't do much for your credibility
with the rest of the women in the tribe
and that your mates might take the piss
out of you uh so I i' certainly
understand from that
that angle for the women as well that
are listening the all consuming fear as
a guy of seeing a girl across the room
and looking at her and thinking I should
go and say hello because I think that
she's nice is like [__] mortal it's
reality bending it's so strange it's
such a bizarre and again I'm sure that
there's loads of guys listening to I
don't know what you're talking about I
can just go up and talk to anybody but I
think even the average normal risk
aversion man has this pretty sort of
gutteral sense of trepidation before
they go and do it absolutely yeah and
yeah the most confident man it doesn't
matter they're going to be a little bit
nervous at least approaching a woman and
I think that's something in pickup
artist communities that they've kind of
caught on to is almost kind of an
exposure therapy to that which you know
exposure therapy when people have
phobias they're exposed gradually to
whatever the stimulus is that reduces
that fear and so maybe they've kind of
caught on like approach a 100 women and
you will be less afraid yeah that's what
it is but of course most men aren't out
there approaching 100 women and that
kind of nervousness it persists even if
an individual is very very confident to
begin with yeah I think that was
definitely one of the positive sides of
the pickup world was that it taught men
to overcome approach anxiety just
through exposure therapy right it
gamified exposure therapy uh which is
pretty reliable when you're trying to
get rid of all manner of phobias if it's
a spider that you're scared or you
agobia and you don't want to leave the
house you know it's one step step at a
time very very small exposures Etc um
and given that this is such a such a
difficult one I asked uh it was ages ago
but I spoke about um what it's like for
a woman to approach a man and be
rejected and had some really interesting
responses from women that it's really
painful for them because they almost
feel like they've broken the social norm
and still not succeeded so there's kind
of two layers of shame that they've had
to go through as opposed to I guess men
maybe with only one yeah exactly and I
didn't even look at women approaching
men because it is so uncommon you know
even for very attractive men they just
don't get approached that much if a man
gets approached once or twice a year you
know he's a Chad now basically that's
what it is it's it's super uncommon for
men for men to get approached and it is
a violation of those expected gender
roles in a way that you know women will
wait I would and they will say you know
I would prefer to be approached by a man
and that's something else that kind of
came out in the research you know we
asked women uh would you like to be
approached more and you had about 70 to
80% of women particularly younger women
even more than older women that said
yeah I wish men would approach approach
more but but they're not going to do it
the women aren't going to going to
approach men for sure interesting so
have you looked longitudinally at this
do you know if men's risk aversion and
fear of approach has increased over time
I don't know for sure but there I think
there is some research on that that I
that I haven't done that's uh looked at
risk aversion in younger generations and
they may be more risk Avers so it might
be something that we see particularly
with the Zoomers right with the younger
generation that they are more
risk-averse than earlier generations and
there's a lot of kind of converging
evidence on that that you know they're
waiting later in life to take risks like
getting a job going to school getting a
driver's license many of these other
things that would indicate okay they're
they're they're kind of hesitant to
enter the adult world so to speak yeah
Jee Tang's work in Generations is is
fantastic with this uh slow life
strategy or extended adolesence um it
explains an awful lot you know me and
bus have been talking about this
generalized risk aversion syndrome um
and it is it's across you know it
permeates absolutely everything but it
really really shows up in dating because
dating is largely a game of Risk
remediation right it's how can I kind of
deal with the inevitable uncertainty of
going up to someone I don't know if they
like me I don't know if they're single I
don't know if I'm going to look silly uh
it very much is uh kind of like the
Vanguard of risk I suppose other things
move out of the house changing jobs
moving locations but certainly a much
lower Stakes more common one which is
what makes it interesting because it is
low States it's like what you get
rejected by somebody when you go up to
them like what's there's literally no
cost apart from a tiny little bit of
discomfort and yet it the felt sense of
it is a you know world-ending
catastrophe exactly yeah and something
kind of related to that is that uh we
see for example individuals higher in
the dark Triad they have more sexual
partners uh Psychopaths as well people
that score high in the hair psychopathy
checklist we see example people that
have a criminal record may have earlier
sexual debuse so they're having sex
earlier in life or having more partners
and these are also all things that are
associated with a higher tolerance for
risk or even risk seeking individuals
who might enjoy risk more so it's kind
of like why do they have more Partners
or something like that it there's some
indication that they might actually even
select down so it might not be that
they're more attractive but it could be
that they're much more tolerant of risk
or that they even seek risks out so
these are the people kind of approaching
more aggressively and so they're kind of
reaping the fruits of that so to speak
was it you that discovered 50% of men
aged 18 to 30 haven't approached a woman
in the last year yes that sounds right
yeah throwing that statistic all over
the Internet so I'm glad I'm glad that I
got the citation right yeah and the men
that have approached are doing
remarkably well a lot of the men who
have approached they they more than half
have gotten a date from it you know and
it goes down if you look to like
long-term relationships how many dates
turn into a long-term relationship but
the men who are approaching they're
doing pretty well
actually okay so 50% of men aged 18 to
30 haven't approached a woman in the
last year of that 50% 50% of them did
get a date I would have to check again
but it might even be higher it might
have been of the men who had it might
have even been about 70% at least got a
date or a phone number or some kind of
romantic connection there and it goes
down to about 20% that got a long-term
relationship out of it but sex is higher
so you kind of see it go down like date
sex is a little bit lower long-term
relationship is a little bit lower but
mostly they're yeah they're kind of
people that approach women they're
getting dates from it that's I don't
know that seems pretty positive for the
approach and I suppose you know there's
there's an argument to be made well of
course the kind of guys that are
approaching women they're the ones that
are full of the confidence or they're
the ones that know it's a sure thing of
course they're getting into
relationships and having sex and going
on dates and getting phone numbers and
stuff
but given the fact that this is an
exclusively agentic uh decision that
you're making right yeah sure if you
have a little bit more confidence in
yourself it's going to make making the
decision more easy but ultimately
there's a huge chunk of people in that
50% that are doing it that probably are
just as unsure and just as terrified and
just as uncertain as you are so yeah I
mean that's a a serious white pill for
why you should approach women absolutely
yeah that's one of the things that I've
come to believe is that you know as as
far as the whole Pua thing and all of
that goes yeah like a lot of it just
comes down to approaching women and it
does seem to work it's interesting you
said agentic as well because I have some
more data I haven't put it out yet but
this looks at like Locust of control and
dating difficulties so I asked people to
list all of these what do they think are
there difficulties in dating and then I
coded those into a survey got the
responses and I found a correlation with
Locust of control and dating difficulty
so individuals that have a higher
internal locus of control that are more
agentic they tend to report that they
have fewer difficulties dating so that's
another thing too is that more agentic
individuals in that sense like you said
yeah they're probably doing better yeah
I think William Costello's most recent
post about incels found a wildly
externalized locus of
control exactly yeah his recent paper
exactly that he looked at the same thing
locus of control and incels had yeah
that higher external Locust of control
you know people with an external locus
of control they see the world as like
things just happen to me it's out of my
control whereas people within internal
locus of control you know they say I
make things happen things don't just
happen to me you know what whatever
happens in life I have some control over
that yeah you asked people that survey I
really loved it you asked people about
the biggest struggles with dating they
were experiencing that were holding them
back what were the big takeaways that
you learned from that well a big one
that emerged was fear of rejection for
men specifically uh dating apps a lot
said you know they just don't well do
well on dating apps that was another big
one a lot had to do with compatibility
and particularly some big uh sex
differences there about 70% of women
scored highly which was a six or a seven
on a seveno liyer scale and said I can't
find someone that I'm intellectually
attracted to which is something that I
didn't expect to be so high but
apparently not being able to make an
intellectual connection was one another
difference was a lot of women uh much
more than men said that they felt there
was a lot of sexual pressure and demand
for them so those are those are things
as well not finding someone who was
physically attractive enough yeah women
scored higher in that as well I think
that had a Cohen D of about .6 so about
a mediumsized difference there so those
are all things like I can't find someone
I'm attracted to I'm afraid to approach
people because I'm afraid to be rejected
can't make a connection with someone on
an emotional or intellectual level as
well the intellectual one is so
interesting and kind of runs against I
think a lot of common held dating
commentary uh on the internet because
it's very difficult for us to quantify
what intellectual compatibility or
saposexual success actually is right
like what no one's talking about that on
the internet you know they'll say and I
hear this Soho house as a research base
for you to go out of should be one of
the first places that you look at if you
sit around the pool at any Soho House on
a Saturday afternoon in a relatively
warm country you will get so many
fascinating stories about girls in the
from 25 to 40 and they dating challenges
and dude I it's my ethnographic like
in-person Research Center and I'll just
sit and just ask questions or overhear
conversations about what people are
talking about and a lot of the
conversations that these girls are
saying is you know guys are um
intellectually immature emotionally
immature um they don't really understand
how to take care of themselves and then
I say okay so have you tried dating
older like if you looked at you know 30
35 40 they say yeah and you know these
problems aren't necessarily solved by
the passage of time
that there are you know adult infants
and and and sort of Manchild all over
the place and again with this it it
would be the low resolution solution to
this would be don't don't worry about
trying to become intellectually or
emotionally interesting or mature just
earn more and you will be able to offset
your emotional immaturity that would be
kind of common held internet wisdom at
least for a lot of
men yeah exactly I think a lot of people
don't think about that and something I
noticed when I followed up and I and I
saw that it was so big on that
intellectual compatibility I asked
people what does that mean to you when
you see a question like that and a lot
of men interpret it to mean like but I'm
very intelligent I have a very high IQ
and I don't think that's exactly what
women uh mean when they're when they're
saying I can't find a man who is
intellectually compatible I don't think
they they mean everyone is stupid or
they're not high IQ I think they mean is
it someone that's interesting that can
uh connect to me emotionally that can
connect to me on a on a mental LEL and
relate to me which is related to
cognitive abilities part of what's
called social cognition theory of Mind
how well do you understand the emotional
states of another person how well can
you predict accurately what the other
person is thinking I think not being
boring is actually a really big part of
it as well as far as that intellectual
compatibility if you have nothing that
you relate on you know being able to
relate to someone is probably a big part
of it where if everyone's hobbies are
different you know someone could be
really smart but you still might not
find intellectual compatibility that so
it's not necessarily men are stupid I
think everyone's dumb but it could be
kind of like you said you know I have a
hard time relating to these men they
seem very immature in that sense yeah I
think just paying attention to people
seems to be incredibly rare you know
it's kind of I guess guys talk about
this a lot that um it sometimes seems to
men that when they're in a relationship
women respond to them differently them
when they're not you know they're just
sat around a dinner table or a bar or
whatever just having a chat and I wonder
whether that kind of gets rid of a few
things the fact that you're if you're in
a committed relationship you're not
trying to pull so it actually does a
couple of things it lowers the stakes
because you're not there's no such thing
as rejection here she's not on the
docket as far as you're concerned and I
also wonder whether um some of the sort
of chest beating peacock tail fluffing
that kind of goes on when guys feel like
they need to do a thing to impress a
girl and maybe even counter signals that
they don't like whereas the dude that
sits back and asks what she's interested
in or just kind of lets this person
waffle on at them uh actually comes
across as being more intellectually
engaging because they're just letting it
come and go nice and easily yeah exactly
some fluency in conversation there is
probably really related to it as well
because something we know about sex
differences in intelligence is that men
tend to score a little bit higher in
Visos spatial but women tend to score a
little bit higher in verbal intelligence
so women may be a little bit better at
communicating and having those
conversations holding them and and
engaging and so if if men are not in
general you know if they're a little bit
worse women might struggle to find that
like is this someone that can kind of
just Ramble On in a sense can they can
they hold an interesting conversation in
that way and I think that might also be
related to kind of what they think of
when they say intellectually compatible
yeah how is your onean crusade to try
and fix the cognitive distortions in the
incel world going
it's going well I think a lot of people
you're a liar you are a liar you a
liar yeah I don't know people are always
very stuck in what they believe ideology
is very very hard to shift and people
like kind of simple explanations for
things kind of univariate explanations
like this is this whereas human behavior
is very very multivariate there's so
many different things that contribute to
why someone might do well at dating or
not you know why someone might come
across as attract Ive or not and people
tend to focus very exclusively on just
one thing without taking into account
the big picture and these become belief
systems that people adopt ideologically
in a sense and shifting their beliefs in
a way is also kind of difficult because
it's almost like it can cause cognitive
dissonance but it's also perhaps
abandoning an identity that they relate
with and I think you see that yeah
particularly in incel communities you
know they that Community is their
friends and their identity in a way what
do you wish more
incel uh
Forum inhabitants
new well I wish that they would
perhaps understand more Nuance as far as
uh all of the research related to
attractiveness so it's very I guess if
it was a specific thing that I wish they
knew perhaps interpreting effect sizes
because you will see in a lot of papers
and it's kind of a statistical thing
you'll see that in the abstract word of
a report like ah the more attractive
person got more women XYZ or you know
the dark people with the dark Triad were
more attractive they had more Partners
but then you will look at the effects
and it will be like one on average or
something like that and that's very
common in Psychology that sometimes the
differences are are relatively small uh
but I don't know if people always
understand that when they're just
reading the abstract or the results
initially that just because there's a
significant effect it doesn't always
mean that it's a meaningful or a large
effect yeah Williams most recent study
I've got part of the abstract here
incels significantly overestimate the
importance of physical attractiveness
and financial prospects to women and
underestimated the importance of
intelligence kindness and humor incels
underestimated women's overall minimum
mate preference standards as
well yeah that's the thing and that and
of course that's part of basically that
whole black pill ideology that looks
reign supreme and and you could say that
and there's some research that would
support that right that looks are often
they're very important no one can deny
that they're they're up there as far as
the hierarchy goes but if you say only
looks matter and everything else uh
doesn't contribute at all that's not a
very good picture either I did a met a
meta analysis looking at lifetime sexual
partners and uh physical attractivness
and the effect was very small it had a
Hedges G of like 0.14 so it's like okay
speak Alex what's that yeah what just it
means a very small effect so if it's
three in Psychology that's about average
so we're looking at something that's
pretty small so it's kind of like uh
yeah more attractive men they have more
sexual partners over the lifetime but
not very much it's not a really big big
difference so there's other things going
on there a lot of those are behavioral
how do men with a lot of sexual partners
act differently and they might be a big
difference might be they seek them out
uh there's larger effects for something
like behavioral dominance for example
what do you mean that behavioral
dominance uh kind of aggression
interpersonal aggression male male
competition even things like athleticism
in sports participating in a competitive
sport those are things actually that
predict having more sexual partners
better than Than Physical attractiveness
does and again this can kind of go back
to risk aversion and impulsiveness
risk-seeking that men who might seek out
those environments they're typically not
the kind of men that are afraid to
approach women and shoot their shot it's
a whole Suite of different things but
yeah I I you know competence is sexy you
see you see a a girl who's good at
pickle ball or something even if you
don't care about pickle ball and you're
like yeah that's that's like kind of hot
like it's cool that that she's able to
do something she's got physical control
of her or a good singer or a good poet
or whatever you know like it kind of
doesn't matter what it is but any degree
of competence and especially anything
that approaches Mastery is just it's
sexy it's
cool yeah exactly especially for men and
David bus he ran of course a large
multinational status or multi
multinational study on on status ques
for men and yeah a lot of the ones at
the top are basically signals of
competence two of them were having a
higher level of education or attending a
prestigious University earning more
money those sorts of things so yeah all
these signals of competence especially
for men seem really important as far as
uh attracting women and even that could
be related to something like
intellectual compatibility if you're
having a conversation with someone and
they seem like like uh they don't know
what they're talking about they haven't
done anything that would indicate some
kind of Mastery or expertise perhaps you
would think like that's not someone On
My Level intellectually why do you think
it is the case then that there is a a
meta meme on the internet of
intelligence kindness and humor not
really being all that important and yet
in the data it seems like that actually
is in your survey 79% of women said that
they were struggling to find somebody
that they were intellectually compatible
with how what's the reason that this
appears to be overlooked especially in
the sort of Insel World well I think for
one everyone thinks they're really smart
everyone thinks they're really funny and
so so they might think but I'm all of
these things I have a really good
personality right A lot of people think
that about themselves maybe they don't
and so they don't see that uh they're
not reaping the rewards from that
because they don't actually meet those
criteria another could be because you
know part of that Meme is probably true
that you know if someone is very very
low in looks or something like that you
know but they they are interesting and
funny and all that yeah they can they
can still struggle more in dating if
they're not hitting that bar that
threshold so to speak you know friend
zone in in that sense right yeah this is
one of the things that I think I
realized when I first started
researching some of the incel forums
they are inhabited by you know some
unbelievable percentage of them have
physical disability many of them are
neurod Divergent in one form or another
and what you have is people who are
really really out on the tail when it
comes to sort of uh just normative um
like everything right and what that
means is
that the philosophy that is derived from
the people out on the Tails gets used by
the people that actually start to move a
little bit closer toward the bell curve
so you know yeah if you're somebody who
physically presents in a really really
unusual way absolutely like LMS very
well may be the hierarchy that's most
important to you looks money status in
uh black pill language um but I'm not
convinced that that's true as soon as
you meet the you know the the standard
threshold but again it's very
unfalsifiable a lot of the the phos ophy
is um that that's just cope or that it's
uh stated versus revealed preferences
from women that they don't actually care
about intelligence and kindness and
humor because they're just going to go
home with Giga Chad in any case that it
is just going to be you know an Andrew
Tate disciple that's going to come in
and sweep her off her feet no matter
what like alpha fox beat the books blah
blah blah like it's very very
unfalsifiable which is why when I see
you venture into these debates and
discussions one-on-one on Twitter that I
kind of applaud you I I don't I never
get involved but I applaud you from the
sidelines for trying to stand your
ground yeah I think what you said is is
important and it's kind of related to
how I see it as well it's better to
understand looks as kind of a threshold
like a bar that must be met rather than
something that where at increasing
levels it just keeps returning
exponential benefits so to speak as soon
as someone hits that threshold like okay
this person passes you know as they as
they call it in the black fi the looks
test they pass the looks test then
everything else kind of comes into play
right and someone can pass that looks
test but if they don't have any of those
other things they might still struggle
in dating a lot that's actually really
really important for women because women
meet a lot of people who do pass the
looks test right and then they have to
compare their options with one another
you know but do they have all of these
other things to because it's not that
women are are necessarily short from
options
but as far at least as far as looks go
because to use an example I ran a study
with faces um uh months and months and
months back
and I picked faces from the Chicago face
database that were pre- as being below
average in attractiveness and I had the
participants rate them again so below
average attractive strong correlation
there agreement that these are less
attractive faces and then instead of
asking rate these spes I put them up
just a binary would you date yes or no
and all of these spces got about 25% of
women that said they would so most women
don't have to like the individual only
some percentage of women have to like
the individual right you don't need 100%
of women and that seems to be very
common that uh looking at research on
faces that agreement from women on faces
is much lower than it is agreement for
men men agree they correlate much
strongly in their ratings of an
attractive female face than women do for
an attractive male face so there's a lot
of more variation for women and that
means that you know a lot of men no
matter what they look like they're not
going to be attractive to most women and
when they are it's important that they
have other qualities and criteria that
facilitate it past that point like okay
he looks okay what do you think most
people misbelieve about online dating
you know we've gone through many
generations of myth and meme about what
online dating is and isn't what do
people misunderstand about the world of
online dating well a a very common
popular perception is that online dating
apps are used to facilitate hookups most
people use online dating to facilitate
long-term relationships between 20 30%
tend to say okay I'm using it as a
hookup app the rest are saying I'm not
engaging in hookups I'm engaging in
long-term relationships another has to
do kind of with how much people
extrapolate from matches and swipes
right that match rates for women are of
course much much higher a big part of
that is because the ratio on these apps
is very imbalanced right there's many
many more men on these apps can be 3 to
one it can be as high as 7 to one the
statistics aren't always clear because
the apps don't tend to release that but
these are things that can skew these
match rates but then when you look
Beyond match rates when you look at
messages when you look at people who
report uh having met from these dating
apps then you begin to start to see a
pretty close one one ratio that at least
for the people who are able to get some
matches they seem to kind of facilitate
sexual encounters relationships
relatively well yeah it's interesting
that most people would think that it's a
Freewheel in casual sex
Marketplace
and is that from men as well men are
saying that I'm not just on here looking
for casual sex I'm on here looking for a
long-term relationship yeah that is that
is for men about 70% long-term
relationship about 30 and of course I
think a lot of men if casual sex landed
in their lap they would probably be open
to it but if you ask them like what are
you really looking for you know men have
kind of a a orientation a lot of the
time we think of men having a strong
orientation toward casual sex but men
kind of have both men have a strong
orientation toward casual sex but also a
strong desire for long-term monogamous
relationships and it's a little bit
different from women when I've run
surveys asking these questions for
example how much do you want a
monogamous relationship men and women
pretty similar you know both indicate
High orientation toward monogamy but if
you ask how open are you to Casual Sex
that's when you begin to see a
difference that men are much more open
to casual sex women hardly open at all
so men are kind of open to either but
tend to desire a committed relationship
I read this great study on online dating
apps that looked at uh partner
preferences for education and
attractiveness think you actually ended
up putting me on to this so fictitious
profiles with manipulated levels of
education and photo attractiveness send
random invitations for a serious
relationship to real online datas we
find that men and women prefer
attractive over unattractive profiles
regardless of their own attractiveness
no surprise there we also find that high
educated men prefer low educated over
High educated profiles as much as high
educated women prefer I high educated
over low educated profiles with
preferences is similar for
attractiveness but opposite for
Education two groups are more likely to
stay single unattractive low educated
men and unattractive High educated
women yeah exactly so the rule there for
men on online dating I guess you know be
attractive be educated go back to yeah
go back to school and for women yeah
kind of kind of the opposite stay out of
school but be very hot I guess but
really you know women so there's there's
kind of something there that you know as
as far as preferences go women tend to
want a man who is a little bit higher in
status than they are and it's still the
case in Western society as much as
people kind of uh like to say degrees
don't matter and all of that it's still
a very robust status signal having a
degree having some level of education
and I think for men there might even be
a current stigma in modern times towards
women who have uh higher education they
might think okay she's kind of a boss
babe she's too bossy she's too masculine
they might think she's she's going to be
um more liberal perhaps or more feminist
or something like that so there are some
negative stereotypes we see now
associated with more educated women but
I guess something important to remember
in in all of that if people are looking
at this and thinking like should I be
this way they're taking it kind of
normative is that men and women both
with a higher level of Education they're
much less likely to get divorced they're
much less likely to have relationship
problems higher relationship
satisfaction so really everyone really
should be thinking like you know ideally
I would have a highly educated mate if
it's a man or a woman but you know there
are kind of those those stereotypes
there yeah it's a difficult one man the
what is it for every standard deviation
increase in a woman's IQ her chance of
marriage drops by
35% I think and it's literally the
inverse for men I'd be really interested
to see this stuff uh replicated now and
you people can always say ah but that
that wouldn't be the case now about a
study that was that's only 10 years old
or 15 years old but I I do think that
we're in a changing time uh with more
women going to University more women
being socioeconomically successful there
has to be an awful lot of pressure on
both men and women to begin to skew
their preferences around what they think
here because you're just going to end up
in a like sex ratio hypothesis hell if
you don't right you you you're going to
have to nudge your preferences
eventually or well I mean you don't
necessarily everyone can just sort of
split off into their own like siloed
like sex siloed worlds but that seems
realistic it doesn't seem realistic to
me so I think that it would be
interesting to replicate some of these
preferences especially around
education uh wealth level wealth
disparity um to just see more than
anything whether a change in the
imbalance between men and women which we
are seeing is able to nudge this or
whether these are kind of like the
thermodynamics of sex difference dating
attraction yeah exactly that's a tricky
situation in the modern environment
especially in Europe you seeing many
more women going to University than men
and at the same time we kind of see that
preference which is a stated preference
that women would prefer a man who has a
similar level of Education or more so
it's kind of like what do we do for that
you know I try to encourage men I see
yeah stay in school you know at least as
far as like dating and stuff goes yeah
it's it's get that piece of paper even
if you know that's going to help is that
enough is that enough of a reason to go
to the university or whatever I don't
know about that but as far as it goes we
know yeah that it's a signal that that
is attractive to women and as far as it
goes for women you know if if we're
going to see a lot of women working
making more money you know we're seeing
this wage Gap that's basically
disappeared and we we see women emerging
with more education they might have to
kind of settle in that sense they might
have to kind of adjust their preferences
or there's not going to be enough men to
go around in a sense yeah yeah it's an
interesting one I um I wonder about the
sort of male
men's concern about what women are are
looking for and there was that uh a
study as well that I found only one
profile out of 100 was liked by more
than 80% of women so as you said earlier
on um attractiveness especially facial
attractiveness it's almost impossible to
be liked by everybody right and that's
that's literally what that study found
that only one profile out of 100 and you
might say well this is because women are
being too choosy or another equally
valid explanation is that women vary
massively in what they find attractive
right that if you have high variants
that also means that trying to find a
face that threads the needle of 100
different women's very unique like
idiosyncratic uh preferences is
impossible exactly yeah yeah female
variance for uh ratings of
attractiveness male faces it is it is
higher in that sense women agree less
and I would like to see that profile of
the guy who got 80% that that liked it
because that is remark remble and I
think that's one of the things that
discourages people about dating apps if
they're like oh I swiped 100 times I
only got five matches or something like
that it's like you got five matches and
out of those five people can you not get
a date you only need one you don't need
80% of people to like you and 80% of
people are never going to like you you
know if it's men women or whatever the
case may be but yeah it's those are the
statistics I think that kind of
discourage people when they see them but
the implications are perhaps not as as
profound in that sense CU it's like yeah
you you just need someone you don't need
all of them to like you Seth Stevens dtz
had a really interesting Insight in this
where he leaned into his nerdy look so
he used a website to split test
different versions of his own appearance
beard no beard glasses no glasses long
hair short hair like how should I dress
all the rest of it and then used use
that data and what he found was that and
this is women that were rating him what
he found was that the more that he
leaned into his nerdy look the more um
extreme attraction results he got back
back and he ended up F he said it
himself on the episode to me he's like
dude I am punching way out of my league
my Miss but when her friends you know
the six months before they met and she
said that she was ready to get back on
the dating Market or something and her
friends asked her what is it that you're
into and you know go around the group or
whatever and I'm into like tall guys or
I'm into like athletic sort of guys got
to her and she says I love nerds I'm
really really super attracted to nerds
so had he have diluted down the more
extreme sides of his
uh physical appearance and the way that
he presents and what he talks about he
would have ended up missing out on
basically outsized returns in The Mating
Market uh because he would have his
partner would have passed him by uh yet
it's an interesting one what about um
Dad bods what have you learned about
dadbods so every once in a while on
social media people will post a picture
or you know basically one of those body
fat comparison pictures that you often
see if you follow bodybuilding and all
of that where it shows like here's
someone with 30% here's someone with 25%
here's someone with 20 and so on and it
will get down to you know guys who are
stage lean who are just jacked and very
lean and if you ask women which body do
you prefer a lot of women will say I
prefer the dad bod right which is a guy
who maybe is a little bit in shape but
not very much and this seems to be
something that women pretty consistently
say but you know there's a lot of
discourse on that like is that true and
so I asked women I said why why do you
like the dad bod why do you not like
these other uh bodies because we also
see that these other bodies do emerge in
female fantasies for example the covers
of romance novels which you know is kind
of the erotic material consumed by women
those are not Dad bods those are usually
someone who looks like a fitness model
you see you know chip andell's dancers
you see for example the calendars with
the sexy firemen anytime women uh
consume kind of a visual erotic material
even if it's a very light it tends to be
someone who actually is kind of jacked
and all that and and the men are
described the same way within those
novels they don't tend to be described
as a dad B they tend to be described to
someone who's tall and you know kind of
lean he's got abs and that sort of a
thing so I asked women you know why do
you like this this Dad bod and and a lot
of it was like ah the bodybuilder he
comes across is narcissistic he he would
make me insecure he might cheat on me so
there's kind of a lot going into that
that it's like H do women prefer these
BDS perhaps because they signal some
kind of comfort they're not as
threatening to women and even the idea
of a man who's more muscular and larger
you know evolutionary women have a
trade-off in their selection of mates a
strong man who's tall and physically
imposing can protect them but he also
represents more of a physical threat to
them at the time so you have a lot of
different converging things that might
make a lot of women say you know I would
prefer uh the dad bod someone I'm who
makes me feel comfortable in a sense as
opposed to like the really jacked
Fitness mod mod kind of guy what when
you're saying that women some say that
they prefer the dad bod over the stage
lean
guy what about if they given a much more
normal you know 10% 11% body fat guy who
has a good amount of muscle mass what
what happens to the skew if you get rid
of the extreme sort of bodybuilder body
do you know well very it's very rare
that women if they see the extreme
bodybuilder they very rarely seem to say
like that's it it tends to be more of of
the leaner kind of fitness model but
still much more muscular than the
average man but still in that case they
tend to say you know I don't want that I
want kind of the fluffier guy what sort
of body fat do you think they end up
settling on can you remember I would
think it would be between 20 and
15 wow wow all of the guys on a permac
cut you don't need to do it anymore just
let cheesecake yourself into a new
relationship with a hottie yeah I I
remember one of my friends who's been
through all manner of different Fitness
Pursuits he's done weightlifting he's
done powerlifting he's done bodybuilding
he did Fitness modeling good-looking kid
and his ex-girlfriend who is no longer
with anymore perhaps this is a a
contributing reason why uh once said to
him as he was prepping for a show and
sort of dialing in his body and getting
down to be super lean she said um I've
never been happier with you than when
you were powerlifting and for anybody
knows what power lifters look like
they're in that sort of 15 to probably
maybe even 25% you know as you get up
toward the super Heavies they're fluffy
they're a fluffy bunch and um yet she
said that she'd never been happier than
when that was the body type that he
presented with and I I think uh you know
a concern about intrasexual competition
about mate poaching
um that must contribute a good chunk of
it you know kind of the it's not quite
the same but guys that are concerned
about their partner posting bikini
photos on the internet you know a dude
in a sufficiently well-fitted t-shirt
who's walking around a 8% body fat
vascular as hell and and with a good
amount of muscle mass yeah it's not you
can see what's going on here right you
can you can make a lot of inferences
about what's what's happening underneath
the t-shirt in kind of the same way that
a super party hugging dress does for
women exactly yeah and something else
kind of related to that in the sech is
individuals who have Partners who are
more attractive if they're men or women
uh they experience more jealousy so it
could be that that you know if someone
is more conventionally attractive
they're going to be getting more
attention perhaps it evokes more
jealousy they're going to be afraid like
you said of mate poaching they're going
to be afraid okay this person might
cheat and there is some actually
indication that for men but not for
women that men who are a little bit more
attractive might commit infidelity a
little bit more they're going to have
more sexual partners so there can be
that perception and it's not maybe
perhaps totally inaccurate that okay if
you get a guy who's very attractive he's
got a great body or something like that
uh is he going to stay committed to you
is he more likely to cheat and that's
kind of something that that women said
you know that he seems like he seems
like he could be narcissistic he cares
too much about his appearance and you
know I would worry about him being
unfaithful yeah it's I've always thought
about this that somebody that's in good
condition physically it says an awful
lot about them Beyond simply what it's
going to feel like to get them naked in
bed you know if if somebody has trained
consistently for a decade you know so
much about them you know that they're
probably not a massive degenerate
Drinker because it would be very
difficult to stick to the protocol if
you did that that they are reliable that
they can deal with discomfort that they
are able to overcome hard things that uh
they've got like a pain tolerance which
kind of sexy right like you know a whole
Litany of different things discipline
reliability they've probably got a a
pretty robust friend group from going to
the gym all that sort of stuff and that
you just you tell that but it's kind of
a little bit like a hidden signal
because the only people that really know
that are other people that also go to
the gym and it's not the first thing
they think the first thing they think is
look at the nice shoulders or the good
ass or whatever it is that they're
looking at but the people that have
spent enough time decoding what this
means and I do think that it probably
percolates somewhere in the back of your
mind is that's probably quite a reliable
person but uh yeah you also end up with
a bit of a difficulty on the bodybuilder
side I wonder whether this is part of
the Allure of CrossFit athletes that
because it's not done specifically for
Aesthetics guys are able to get
themselves into good condition whilst
not seeming like they care overly about
that sort of narcissistic side of stuff
yeah that could be because there was
that perception as well that it's kind
of a vain behavior and in that sense
almost an unmasculine behavior is what
some people said that you know it's like
you should not care so much about your
appearance as a man basically it's
almost a uh but if you're jacked from
doing Brazilian jiu-jitsu or chopping
wood or doing some other thing your body
has come along as a byproduct of a
Pursuit that you actually care about so
I remember a while ago and I got a lot
of stick for this on the internet I
remember reading a study a theory that
said one of the reasons why women prefer
dadbods is this uh caloric Choice idea
so um a man that is really good-looking
and and and like lean and in good
condition if you give him one calorie
there is there are more Avenues open to
him outside of his committed
relationship and his family to which he
could spend that calorie right so the
resources have more different angles for
him to go down because there's going to
be other mating opportunities so on and
so forth whereas the guy that was the
soft fluffy dad bod would presumably
have more doorways of potential
infidelity closed to him which actually
means that he it was that Dad bods are
an indication of better dads was the
thought that he's not going to spend his
calorie trying to chase after some 21y
old because she doesn't care about him
so I thought that was uh another
interesting kind of second order effect
of the way that women perceive their
current matate uh level of um potential
strain yeah exactly yeah and and what
you said there dad bods are indicative
of better dads I think that's very
insightful and important because yeah it
is kind of a contrast between long-term
versus short-term mate selection when
people you know women have a strong
orientation towards long-term very few
women have a strong orientation towards
short-term so when you see women Express
their preferences they're often talking
about in the context of who would I date
who would I like to have a relationship
with perhaps not as often as you know
who would I like to have a one night
stand with and maybe that's why we see
Dad bods selected if you post those
pictures they'll say yeah this is kind
of what I would like they're thinking
about a long term but then you maybe see
the more ripped jacked guy appear as a
character in female fantasies where it's
more sexually oriented because within
the context of a fantasy it's safe but
that doesn't mean that that same man
would be safe in the context of a real
life relationship yeah what are they
called I'm pretty sure there's a name
for them are they not called like
cinnamon rolls or golden retriever men
or something I'm pretty sure this shows
how terminally online I am that I know
this but I'm absolutely sure that
they're called cinnamon roll men or
golden retriever men um and yeah the
dichotomy that you have in female
erotica is saying why are there no like
why is grandma porn not a really popular
type of pornography for men to consume
many men love their grandmother and
you're like well yeah but like I it's
horses for courses here and for women
the thing that they fantasize about
might not be the thing that they want to
get into a relationship with long term
uh one other thing that I thought was
fascinating you've been talking about a
lot recently is the libido Gap what's
that so the libido Gap yeah basically
the observation that there's a sex
difference in libido in sexual desire
well there's a sex difference in sexual
desire attitudes and behaviors and this
is probably one of the largest sex
differences that we see kind of in in
behavioral psychology in a sense you
know a lot of differences between men
and women are small but when it comes to
sexual behavior it's it's pretty large
and this is something you can see from
lines of converging evidence as far as
that goes that men have a higher libido
men have a higher desire to have sex
with more people sex more frequently uh
tend to have more open attitudes toward
casual sex seeking more sexual variety
even if it's within a relationship more
sexual variety as far as like sexual
acts and experimentation that sort of a
thing there's research that indicate
well research very very consistently
across the years across countries
indicates you know men cheat more than
women do that's an example of the libido
Gap as well if you look at research
under fmri and although this isn't
always entirely clear men tend to
respond to erotic images a little bit
more strongly if you look at research
using attention paradigms if you present
for example naked bodies of men and
women it draws the visual attention of
men more as well so men pay more
attention to that so you have all of
these converging lines of evidence that
there is a gap in sexual desire in
libido in attitudes the role of
testosterone of course is a very very
big one we know you know testosterone
Administration to men or women causes
the libido to shoot up and of course men
have much more testosterone than women
naturally which increases that as well
what's the implication of this what's
the implication of there being a big
libbido gap perhaps that men and women
will engage in uh sexual behaviors
differently they will pursue them
differently that men will pursue sex
more frequently in a relationship men
are more likely to pursue sex uh outside
of the relationship more likely to
pursue casual sex and of course there's
some debate on this from I I say debate
but there's not really much debate at
all on this in the scientific literature
very large metaanalysis recently
conducted on the L Beetle Gap found a
difference of about 0.5 so that's about
a mediumsized difference but for
psychology actually quite large so we
know that this is real but there are
people who kind of deny it that say you
know it's cultural or something like
that of course women have the same
amount of libido if you ask men and
women though they both tend to indicate
yeah we know that men have a larger
libido that men are more open to sex
with multiple people and and all of that
yeah I mean if you had women with the
libido style of men reading women's
erotic would include a different man on
each chapter it would be Tom and Jack
and Harry and all the way through but
it's not there tends to be one
protagonist throughout the whole story
right whereas I think what's the average
number of partners that men go through
in a single sexual fantasy it's like
four or something right like four or
five I think that they cycle through in
one sexual fantasy you know for the
women that might be the first time that
you've heard that if you're a woman but
like that's men just like H done with
that one like next one I guess it's like
a a mental coolage effect in some way
right that you've got this this uh
very rapid desire for sexual variety
even when it's just in your
mind yeah exactly there there is that
big difference in a desire for sexual
variety and even in the context of
erotica and women's fantasies you'll
often see that it's kind of a process of
taming that man over time so it's even
almost like a long-term orientation even
in the context of sexual fantasies like
you know it's sexy and all of this but
then at the end they're together in a
relationship and with men it's almost
the the opposite when these sexual
fantasies occur it'll be like casual sex
have sex move on to the next person or
something like that yeah you looked at
uh body count and sexual double
standards what did you learn there so
that's kind of interesting because
there's a lot of discourse of course on
body count primarily on the internet one
of the things that I was curious about
was uh do people even ask you know a lot
of men don't even seem to ask which
could indicate you know because some
people indicate that it's really
important for them right uh a very low
body count to the point that you know
you have men who say you know I would
really prefer a virgin wife and at the
same time you have men that you know say
they don't care at all so I believe it
was about 22 40% of men I would have to
double check said you know I don't even
ask for body countt dat which one way to
interpret that is you know they don't
care that much another could just be
like I don't want to know right then
asking about ideal body count it's
actually pretty similar for men and
women and in the survey that I did and
in past research that seems to be the
case that both men and women seem to
prefer a lower body count in partners of
the opposite sex the ideal it's not zero
if someone's a virgin that seems to be
kind of a red flag both for men and
women surprisingly on average you know
some men do prefer a virgin of course
but seems to be about two to three and
then as it increases it of course drops
off but people seem to be pretty
tolerant of of higher body counts
upwards of 20 Partners in a woman for a
man perceiving a woman upwards of 40 for
a man and that's when people tend to
start saying uh this is kind of a deal
breaker you know and asking people in
the survey as well have you gone on a
date and uh asked about body count and
stopped dating them about 10% of men and
women said uh yes in a committed
relationship even lower I think it was
like two or 3% for women and men so it
doesn't seem to be quite the deal
breaker that a lot of people think that
it is but it's when you get to these
excessively high body counts that that
it does become become a problem then
people look at that they say who what's
going on there exactly Andrew Thomas
taught me about this and if you actually
look at the curve of how it works uh
zero I think for both men and women zero
is about rated about as attractive as
seven 7 to 10 right so it Peaks that the
peak of this is round about sort of
between two and four uh and then zero is
the same as like you know nearly double
digits uh so yeah there is this there is
a little bit of an aversion did women
were women more Avers to male virgins
than men were to female
virgins I didn't find that uh in mind
and I and I think in the other one in
the paper that was by Steve Stewart
Williams and Andrew Thomas that you
refer to I don't think there was that
much of a difference I don't know if
there was a significant difference or
not but if there was it would have been
a small one but there does seem to be
kind of yeah that that aversion there I
guess in practice of course you know if
if you ask are women more averse to The
Virgins they might be because they
remain virgins right but that wouldn't
be because they're virgins that would be
because of whatever else is leading them
to that persistent virginity I suppose
what do you mean when you talk about
sexual double standards then how does
that get folded in here sure so the idea
of sexual double standards is attitudes
towards sexual behaviors that are
different for men and women an example
of that kind of in popular culture we
have a saying that says if a key will
open any lock it's a master key but if a
lock is opened by any key it's a bad
lock so that's kind of you know a
parable or something about promiscuity
the idea you know that if a man has sex
with many many many women you know he's
a player he's really good if a woman
does it it's really really bad so
there's some discourse on this more
recent research has indicated okay a lot
of these sexual double standards are
going away they're they're closing you
know some some even have kind of
reversed and particularly when it comes
to things like having sex with a minor
or sexual assault they mostly seem to be
gone so it's kind of like yeah people do
seem to judge these things not as uh
different for men and women at this
point that's interesting what what about
the sexual assault and sex with a minor
thing like what's what what's going on
that sure so an example of that is when
a teacher who is a woman has sex with a
male student when a teacher who is a man
has sex with a female student are these
viewed differently it seems to be you
know if you look at kind of discourse on
it that they are kind of viewed
differently right that men and women you
know if it's if it's a a woman that's
having sex with a minor male students
perhaps is judged less strongly although
some of the recent research on that has
indicated actually that's not the case
that people sent to view this just as
bad but perhaps in the past that was
more the case that you know if it was a
minor male they would view it less
negatively interesting what about the
guys who demand virgins what like who
are these people sure so again related
to body count in that case you do have
people that show a very strong
preference for virginity if you ask men
you know how many past sexual partners
would you preferring a partner we have
kind of that that goldilock zone sweet
spot that's like three or something like
that someone who's not entirely
inexperienced but you do have people
that show a very strong preference for
virgins and who do those tend to be they
tend to be young men who probably are
themselves virgins you know less
sexually experienced they tend to have
lower levels of Education lower levels
of income so that seems to be the case
that you know and it's not entirely an
unreasonable desire or expectation
because if you know if you're a man
who's 18 years old half of the female
population is going to be a virgin if
you're a virgin you know you might want
your first experience to be with someone
else who is at that age those men you
know they don't make a lot of money but
what happens also is you have
individuals who persist in that desire
for virginity uh into an older age at
age 30 or something it's like if you're
a 30-year old man and you're looking for
a virgin that's like you know like two
or three% of the male and female
population at that age women who are 18
years old and virgins typically do not
want to date someone who's 30 35 or
something like that and so it becomes
increasingly unreasonable with age if
men persist in virginity until they're
mid-30s and they say oh I'd still like a
virgin they're going to have to come to
terms with like that's not in the cards
for them yeah it's an interesting one
man I I again I do especially for the
young men like the in the important
qualifier here is especially if you're a
guy that is a virgin you know there's
something it's you're you're going to
feel emasculated by your partner's the
disparity in sexual experience right
your supposed to be here I am my first
time I'm taking charge I'm finally
becoming a man and oh she's teaching me
all of the things that I need to do that
doesn't feel like I don't know that
doesn't seem like the dream that most
men probably perceive for their first
time yeah exactly and there's a lot
that's kind of related to that so
related to sexual double standards we
know for example that men tend to view
other men with more sexual partners is
higher in status and it seems to be that
it's more male male signaling than it is
desirable to women so women actually
rate men that are very promiscuous a
little bit less desirable a little bit
more negatively but for men it's pretty
much a linear relationship like the more
sexual partners you have the more of a
man you are in a sense right that
filters into all of our cultural
narratives and scripts so it's often you
know something that men are encouraged
to believe about themselves that if
they're less sexually successful uh
they're less desirable they're less
attractive but that often that's more
messaging that tends to come from other
men than women I think did you see
Jeremy boring uh tweet earlier on today
about what the red pill is doing to
marriage no no so Jeremy boring CEO of
the daily wire he's been featured on a
lot of their Productions and stuff he
said what uh what the red pill is doing
to marriage basically sort of uh
degrading marriage saying that it's a
bad deal for men etc etc you've looked
at a good chunk of this right what
what's happening with marriage and
divorces like what are the real stats
that people are missing here sure so
yeah as far as the red pill goes it's
you know promotes a lot of very cynical
narratives uh particularly in the
context of marriage and it's you know
not a homogeneous uh ideology or set of
beliefs or whatever but you do see a lot
of discourse on divorce that often just
says you know 50 or 60% of people get
divorced it's mostly initiated by women
okay but there are individual
differences in who gets divorced and who
doesn't you know for every married man
across the board and I think this is
something gets wrong the risk of getting
divorced is not 50% that's going to be
determined a great deal by the
individual characteristics within that
relationship you know what kind of
things contribute to divorce infidelity
is a big one uh alcohol abuse is a big
one economic problems so just by
avoiding you know simple things that you
know are going to cause a divorce flat
out eat Don't drink don't get broke
exactly yeah just these very basic
things is going to drop the divorce rate
way down you know if you look across
demographic groups individuals with a
higher level of Education men and women
both much less likely to be single much
less likely to get divorced so already
being Within These certain demographic
groups drops it way down but you do kind
of have that narrative out there in the
red pill and all of that that you know
marriage is a bad deal for men and they
hear many anecdotes about people who get
divorced and they lose all of their
things or whatever and
yeah yeah Jeremy boring tweeted um the
fact that women initiate 80% of divorce
is evidence that some manifestations of
evil are more common in women something
society and frustratingly Christian
Society has been trying to obscure since
we turned over all of our moral
authority to women in the 20th century
that seems like a very very odd like
claim to make that there's
manifestations of evil that's not for me
to say that like women uh initiating
divorce that there's some like perverse
incentives that could be going on there
there's all manner of reasons why why
this sort of thing Could Happen many of
them are are probably pretty like
unspeakable
but evidence that some manifestations of
evil are more common in women I don't I
mean why why are women why do women
initiate more divorces and and what are
the reasons that they give for that sure
so yeah there's a lot of focus on that
that's kind of the narrative isn't it
that women initiate more divorces and
that kind of puts the onus on women like
oh if you initiate the divorce it's your
fault but there's a lot of different
reasons actually the reasons why women
initiate divorce is very complex topic
so I I'll kind of go through some of
these but because someone initiates a
divorce does not mean that they are at
fault for the divorce right so we do see
for example you know men and women both
men also will admit this you know when
they get divorced I cheated at a rate
about twice that of women uh they're
much more likely to be physically
abusive although some recent research
has called that into question as well
that perhaps domestic violence within
relationships is actually pretty similar
for men and women uh men are more likely
simply to stay in relationships when the
relationship is bad and if they do kind
of want out they're just simply less
likely to ask for the divorce we know
over time over long periods of time
relationship satisfaction for women it
declines faster as well so there's a lot
of reasons why women initiate divorces
but that doesn't necessarily mean that
women destroyed the relationship right A
lot of the time those initiations of
divorce can be responses there's also a
lot of narrative for example that women
get a lot out of divorce that doesn't
seem to be the case when looking at uh
alimony child support and all of these
things It's usually the case that women
enter a state of poverty and stay below
the poverty line for a few years
following divorce and that men tend to
uh remain more financially successful
following their divorces as well and
there's very high agreement in divorc
couples as well on why the divorce
happened both couples tend to indicate
that you know we grew apart is simply
one of the large reasons most divorces
as well if they look at like who
initiated it they often ask whose idea
was this or who brought it up first but
if you ask like did you both want the
divorce you see really agreement there
that both of them are like yeah the
relationship was over so that's also
something to consider it seems to be
rarely the case that it's simply a
unilateral thing you know the
relationship at that point has
deteriorated both people know it she
might ask for it first and that might
emerge in the statistics as the woman
you know initiating the divorce but it's
really rarely the case that the man is
just like chilling and he thinks
everything is perfect and everything's
going well and then she says I want a
divorce and he's just blindsided I don't
know I don't know why that happened and
then she takes everything that's very
very rare that that happens yeah Adam
Lane Smith psychotherapist ex
psychotherapist now relationship coach
you know sat through thousands of
couples across his career and he's
adamant about this that they couple
comes in and sits down and something
catastrophic is about to happen and to
the guy he hasn't it's either willful
ignorance or or just straight up
blindness to many many many signs for
years and years and years from his
partner and you know Adams is you know
he's [__] proen for an awful lot of
this I don't think that he's got any
reason to simp for women's desire to
have no fault divorce or whatever I I
think that he's been truthful when he
just says look like you know guys can
get into a habit that keeps them blind
to what's going on in their relationship
and the female partner gets to the stage
where they
say I like I I there's no more there are
no more hints that I can drop we need to
go to counseling and then they sit down
in counseling and this woman kind of
unloads all of this stuff and the guy
looks across and can't
believe what is coming out of his
partner's mouth uh and yeah I think it's
Adam Adam seemed to think that the a lot
of the time Coupes counseling is done by
a couple as
an almost an excuse by the woman so that
she doesn't feel too guilty like she's
already made her mind up and it's
already so far gone but she needs to
finally be able to actually get all of
this stuff off her off her chest so you
know you could maybe say that this is a
communication problem maybe maybe it's a
failure of cross- sex mind reading
between the Sexes that women are
communicating their discontent and their
issues in ways that men aren't picking
up on that men aren't being sufficiently
perceptive like those would be some ways
but what we understand that women
initiate file for divorce more than men
why do you think that that's the case
like what is it about women their
experience within a marriage that's
causing that to be them that does
it well I think I think if I think
there's a a situation where men will
simply stay in a bad relationship almost
to the end they just men are much less
likely to to kind of end it when all the
writing is on the wall there are very
explicit things that cause divorce you
know as as well drug abuse more common
in men uh infidelity more common in men
and just looking at those two things
that already closes the Gap to who
initiates but then we have other things
as well like declining marital
satisfaction which does decline faster
in women I think women are more willing
to move on in that sense perhaps I think
you know we know for example that in
single women uh they're much more likely
to report being voluntarily single women
are probably more okay than men in many
ways as far as leaving a relationship
and as far as uh not being in a
relationship that they don't want which
can go back to you know all of the
evolutionary reasons women being more
selective and that sort of a thing women
seem to be less pressured to remain in a
relationship when they're genuinely
unhappy with it more ready to move on is
that because ancestrally women would
have had a surplus of potential suitors
so for men it makes sense for them to
remain steadfast and robust even in
their shitty relationship because the
relationship may not be that good but at
least it's a relationship you know most
of my male friends that they haven't got
anybody well I don't know about I don't
know about that for sure because
sometimes we see those bottlenecks in
the wide chromosome which indicates okay
there were actually many more women than
to men so it's almost like if they left
the man would they be able to find
another one I don't know for sure about
that but something that seems to be very
consistent across humans is we have this
the dominant mating pattern is basically
serial monogamy that people you know
unlike the Prairie V or some other
animal we don't tend to mate for life or
with our first sexual partner and stay
with them forever people have some
girlfriends they break up they get
married they might stay married 10 or 15
years they get a divorce they marry
someone else so people have an
orientation toward monogamy that's much
stronger than many of the other Apes
right and we form really long
relationships compared to most mammals
but they don't seem to be lifelong
relationships and that seems to
correspond to kind of the gestational
age I guess or or the developmental age
of children that there is a period of
time when people might need to stay
together to ensure the survival of off
spring it could be also the case as well
that you know not having lifelong
bonding uh can increase genetic fitness
from genetic diversity so if someone you
know has a long-term relationship 15
years they have some Offspring they get
to the end of that time period they
divorce they might still have some time
to have new Offspring with a new mate so
we still have this long-term mate
formation but kind of with some
diversity of Offspring in that case how
do you think we should uh balance the
scales that if what you say is right and
I I I believe that you are right as well
I don't think that Christopher Ryan and
sex at dawn is is perfectly accurate
serial monogamy seems to be what makes
sense ancestral monogamish I think it's
sometimes referred to as but we've
created a cultural world where that is
looked you know Jeremy boring is is a
probably a pretty good example of what
the last 500 years of of uh marital
advice has been that you're supposed to
stay together through thick and thin in
sickness and in health till death death
to us part um we have constructed a
value system even outside of you know
people that are a superch Christian that
you know breakups and divorce and stuff
it's it's not something that you're
supposed to do and you made your
commitment to the partner and you're
going to stick together forever do you
ever think about this uh cultural
mismatch to our sort of evolutionary
predisposition yeah definitely certainly
we have you know the last 2,000 years of
of rules that say you are married to
someone you stay with them for life and
at the same time yeah we have that
mismatch between that and what people
seem to want to do and looking at
research on on love for example there's
different kind of stages of Love or
different components of love one is
called passionate or romantic love and
that seems to be the feeling
neurobiological that people experience
when they say they're in love and that
usually doesn't persist for decades and
decades and some people it does but it
usually doesn't and that tends to wne
after about 3 to 5 years somewhere in
that area and that's kind of consistent
with you know that developmental
trajectory you know people fall in love
they have kids the kid is a little bit
old enough now past that point people
are going to be a little bit more
willing to move on but of course then
there's committed love and all these
other facets of love where people still
maintain really strong bonds almost as a
friendship in a relationship but then
that comes to a point you know 15 years
down the line people might think okay
I'm with a partner I'm very committed to
them we're like best friends uh we have
a lot going there but at the same time
you know that passionate love is missing
they want something else in addition to
that and so they're kind of faced with
that that choice or decision you know do
they just continue in that relationship
or do they kind of move on and restart
the process so to speak and there's not
a good solution or a good answer there
as far as like prescriptive what should
people do and and that's of course where
all of these beliefs like religion and
things come into play that tell people
like you should do this you should do
that and I think even you know even when
people fall out of that passionate love
even if they have a bad relationship
breakups are still often really really
hard for them so it makes a lot of sense
that you know Norms would emerge it say
like just stay together forever it
avoids a lot of problems even you know
if the relationship is not ideal in that
sense yeah it's interesting man this I
don't know I I wonder what a a different
kind of uh religion would have been that
said marriages supposed to stay together
for 10 years and then at that point
there's some weird ceremony where you
you have to prove that you still care
about each other enough and both partner
has to do it independently and some
weird RW shark lie detect a test and
then you come back together and if it
works you do I don't know but um yeah
when you fold on
top contraceptive Technologies and
liberated sexual norms and a sex
positive society and stuff like that it
really doesn't surprise me that we're
seeing divorce rates increasing you know
there's there's an awful lot of
embedded uh genetic predisposition in
there to encourage us to okay like I'm
like we're done we're done here now um
you know one of my favorite ones is um
couples that have stayed together for
quite a while before having children can
often find themselves randomly falling
out of love with each other and there's
an evolutionary explanation for this
which is all almost never would you and
a partner have stayed together for a
long period of time without trying to
have children the only reason that that
would have been the case is if one of
you had a fertility issue and you don't
know if it's you and you don't know if
it's them but you definitely know that
there is a 50% chance that you're going
to have this problem fixed if you decide
to move on and this is you know one of
the concerns for um extending prolonging
the pre- child section of any
relationship uh you know couples that
get together University they're 20 21 22
and they think yeah you know we we we'll
we'll start having kids when we 30 there
can be some risks associated with that
if this Theory turns out to be
right yeah exactly and and that's
another thing too kind of related to
romantic love transitioning into
committed love uh people past that point
they have invested into the relationship
so there's a question of like what
things in that relationship Drive
Commitment if there are kids that might
be a reason to stay together and be
committed and try to work things out for
a longer period but if not you know you
have to wonder I read a blog post from
you that was called the Normie gets the
girl what do you mean when you say the
Normie gets the girl sure so I did this
with some
vignettes descriptions of different
individuals this was related to kind of
uh the ambivalent sexism inventory which
has constructs of hostile sexism and
benevolent sexism and I created
vignettes a man who was basically like a
hostile sexist which is often kind of
negative sexist attitudes toward women
and then benevolent sexism is another
facet of that and this is It's called
sexist by the individuals who created
this inventory but I think there's
reason to question if these are sexist
behaviors they seem to be more
traditional attitudes toward women like
women should be first on the Lifeboat
that sort of a
thing uh and I had women rate you know
how attractive is this man for short
longterm and all of that so short
longterm yeah it's pretty closely
related but
you see that men high in hostile sexism
they get rated pretty low men high in
benevolent sexism tend to get rated a
little bit higher and then I have these
other vignettes one was like a
manosphere beliefs black pill kind of
beliefs rated really really low by women
kind of related to hostile sexism there
and then a Normy vignette a guy who just
thought you know things are fine I don't
get into these you know uh gender War
ideology or whatever the case may be and
that's kind of rated
the highest and so that see you know and
there was another that was an
egalitarian or feminist man kind of
rated medium so there's of course a lot
of discourse on that what kind of men do
women like you know and all of that and
it seems to be the case that women don't
want someone who is super egalitarian or
someone who is super uh feminist
necessarily in a man they don't want a
man at the same time who is highly
misogynist or kind of the manosphere
ideologue they want a guy who's a normal
guy basically who has kind of normal
status quo ideas about women and sex
roles and gender
roles did this change based on the
political leaning of the women in
question did you find that left leaning
women were more open to having a
feminist male partner and vice versa a
little bit but not much I asked women
for feminist identification or not and
the women who did identifies a feminist
they they did rate the egalitarian
vignette a little bit higher but mostly
you still see the same pattern that the
normi is still the most attractive
benevolent sexist man still gets rated
higher than the Hostile sexist man that
sort of a thing what was second was
benevolent sexist man second I believe
the benevolent sexist man was second uh
and I I think for the feminist condition
the benevolent sexist man was second and
I think for the non-feminist condition
there was a man who was kind of a
traditional masculine vignette and I
think that was second but across all of
them yeah kind of the norm guy was the
one that you know the women said they
related to the most well don't forget
you know kind of like we said um
somebody's body is not just the body it
is a representation of many other things
about them their worldview and the way
that they show up and their personality
and all this sort of
stuff the things that you believe about
men and women is also an implication of
how much time is this guy going to spend
on Twitter how much time is this guy
going to spend arguing with people on
Reddit like how often am I going to have
to sit at dinner and hear him hop on
about some weird YouTube video that he's
just watched or whatever you know
there's an implication Downstream from a
lot of
this yeah exactly people see that and
they I think when people see extreme
beliefs and ideology they wonder you
know how stable is this person going to
be and all of that if someone sees
someone who's kind of normal they relate
to them more because you know most
people aren't extreme red pillars or
extreme feminists or something like that
most people do kind of share a mix of
attitudes and you know they might lean a
little bit left a little bit right but
for the most part you know they're not
typically focused on this gender War
ideology and if they think like yeah
especially if it comes to hostile
attitudes toward the opposite sex you
know hostile sexism mosphere whatever
the case may be then it's almost like
you know is my partner going to hate me
you know are they going to getting into
a relationship with a racist as a black
person yeah yeah it's pretty much like
that these are these are beliefs that do
not help people in in dating you know
and they probably manifest in behavior
and even if people never share them in
very subtle ways that are not going to
be entirely fulfilling for the opposite
sex did you see those Tik toks floating
around about a month or a couple of
months ago of uh liberal women lamenting
the fact that they couldn't find any
traditional men that would hold the door
open for them and consider paying on the
first date because all of the liberal
men that they were trying to date they
basically what they described was a like
Cookie Cutter conservative man is what
they wanted yeah exactly and and I think
that's closely related to that what's
called benevolent sexism in the
literature you know and and I I would
dispute myself personally this is not
something I would call sexist but that's
what they called it and it's kind of you
know there's been research that
indicates women prefer men who score a
little bit higher in benevolent sexism
and these are kind of like traditional
conservative attitudes and beliefs there
are things like holds the door or
something like that even if the women
identify as more left so it seems to be
that on the one hand you know if they
think about uh their conscious
preferences they might think you know I
want a man who is uh more egalitarian
but when it comes down to a lot of
behaviors they still expect behaviors
that are very congruent with traditional
gender roles with the man paying for the
bill the man holds the door he picks her
up at her house and so on and and even
physically the same you know as far as
like a man who is uh behaviorally
dominant who's physically masculine and
and all of that yeah it's uh stated in
revealed preferences kind of coming to
the front yet again what's that Talib
quote he says something like um uh
around my family or in the home I'm a
socialist in my neighborhood I'm a
communist at my state level I'm a
Libertarian and at the national level
I'm a conserv some something like that
it kind of feels a little bit like that
that you've got um what a woman might
want Men at Large to be like you know I
would prefer to not have hostile sexism
from this entire 50% of the population
sent toward me and my girlfriends I
would prefer that we had a more
egalitarian world I would the sufferings
and the challenges of women are
understood and the blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah but when it finally comes
down to it the meat and potatoes brass
tax of getting into bed and getting into
a relationship with
somebody you know this is the problem I
think that has largely gone under the
radar but may come back to bite her in
the ass a little bit further down her
career Alex Cooper from call her daddy
uh was you know spent made a career
extoling the virtues of casual sex uh
you know treat him like you don't like
him how to have sex and not catch feels
you know like relationships are kind of
useless and pointless but for the last
three years it turns out that she's been
having this Whirlwind romance with the
guy of her dreams and then she released
a maybe it was a podcast or a post
talking about how beautiful The Proposal
was in a rose garden and he got down on
one knee and it was exactly as she'd
envisioned
and you
go this wasn't the story that you
promised your audience this wasn't the
life that you said that all of the
people following you the millions and
millions and millions of women that were
listening to you should lead and I think
you know I've got this theory about how
hypocrisy is a purpose-built malady for
the intellectual uh technological social
media rage
because you can show it's basically a
before and after a cognitive before and
after photo right this is what you said
previously and this is what happened in
the future you said that getting into a
relationship and marriage was totally
pointless and you extoled the virtues of
your rose garden proposal you it it just
the dissonance like just bleeds out of
all of these conversations and uh yeah I
think stated and revealed preferences
what is it that
is politically socially popular for
women to post about on the internet
compared with what are they actually
going to want to get into a relationship
with at the end of the
day yeah exactly I think as far as
people talk about you know there's
research uh from a feminist perspective
that talks about you know the man should
do more chores in the house and the sex
will be better and all of that but at
the end of the day I think it really is
the case you know that women do not want
to be the man in the relationship they
don't want the man in the relationship
to be the woman they do kind of seem to
want those roles to some extent even if
politically those uh stated preferences
are for a highly egalitarian uh
organization and there's probably some
balance you know where they don't want
to be bombarded with uh the most
restrictive kind of gender roles in a
sense but at the same time you know a
man who's more dominant who's going to
take charge who's gonna lead who's GNA
drive the car and pick the restaurant
you know and that sort of a thing yeah
it's just you know there are certain
elements there are they Associated
typically with masculinity yes but you
like being iive standing well under
pressure uh like it's it is where do you
want to go for dinner tonight I'll just
there we go we'll choose um yeah I think
it's uh it's funny that the memes and
the cliches kind of often hold some of
the greatest truth in them there was
this uh Katherine Walter study on uh
testing assumptions about human mating
psychology deal breakers and mate
preferences 50,000 participants from 56
countries both men and women prefer
short-term Partners who are kind healthy
attract Ive women had higher ideal
preferences for short-term mates than
men did and most participants 59 to 80%
preferred the same type of Ideal mate
for short-term and long-term
relationships what's the implication of
that yeah brilliant and I think this is
that study is very consistent with
pretty much all of the past research in
evolutionary psychology on short and
long-term mate preferences somehow it
has gotten into the popular discourse
that you know an entirely different kind
of person is who is desired for short
and long term but really it seems to be
like no the same traits are desired in
short and long term but some might be
weighted a little bit differently in
small ways on average so you know a man
who's funny and charismatic longterm
short-term both perfect a man who's
physically attractive yeah he's also
desirable both as a long-term and
short-term mate but in short-term mating
context you know physical attractiveness
it might be a little bit higher
preferred but it's kind of like yeah
anyone who's desirable as a long-term
mate is also going to be desirable as a
short-term mate and vice versa yeah man
I don't know the the um this metameme
of having wildly different mating
preferences for both that being said we
said it earlier on you know the person
that you're going to fantasize about is
not necessarily the person you but even
with that let's roll another filter as
you said the hyper masculine guy might
be great to think about when you're
behind the safety of a page right but if
you have this very overbearing
physically sort of dominant guy there's
an awful lot of probably Associated fear
that comes with that in some regards it
can be sexy but in other regards it's
just going to be terrifying you know in
a sort of a post me too world I wonder I
wonder what um sort of times up in me
too as a cultural phenomenon has done to
women's preferences when it comes to
male um behavior and body type and stuff
like that I would not be surprised if we
see women
um you know inculcating this concern
about uh two men that are overly
dominant um and it really wouldn't
surprise me if the end result was we
should opt for more feminized men uh
even if it was only a little bit uh it
would it would be very surprising if it
was the other way yeah exactly you can
see kind of that shift culturally
perhaps towards men who are less
dominant or less threatening and there's
a lot of
assumptions about that kind of related
to the dad bod thing I I posted an image
and it was kind of like Yeah the more
muscular man is is going to be more
threatening someone said you know he
looks like he might be a misogynist so
you see a man who simply because he's
jacked they think he's going to be a
misogynist so you already have kind of
that that Association there so what does
that mean that like the skinny weakling
is is going to be a feminist or
something like that we have kind of
those those associations and if that's
what they think they want is like the
feminist man maybe they're going to pick
the skinny guy but at the end of the day
you know there's probably not too large
of an association between attitudes in
that sense Jim Bros have a branding
problem man they need to go through a an
advertising agency to fix this [__] yeah
yeah and there was a recent study that
was pretty interesting on that that
found okay men who are more muscular are
perceived as being more conservative on
average and I think there's also some
research in the past that indicates that
as well that men with a higher grip
strength for example also tend to be a
little bit more right leaning and they
tend to score a little bit High in
Social dominance orientation so
sometimes these perceptions that people
form they can kind of reflect accuracy
and that's related to Something in
Psychology that that they don't like to
talk about very much it's called
stereotype accuracy because you know we
always say don't judge people based on
stereotypes but at the same time some
stereotypes we form them because we see
frequencies base rates in the population
a lot pattern recognition yeah pattern
recognition exactly six main red flags
gross clingy addicted promiscuous
apathetic and unmotivated perhaps
unsurprising to have those and these
sort of broad buckets seem to be quite
well replicated like within each of them
there's sub genres of promiscuity and
apathy and whatnot my the most
interesting thing that I learned from
that study was women find promiscuity
even less attractive than men in
shortterm
relationships yeah and that's I think a
thing that a lot of men get wrong and
you can tell them this and show them
past papers that found this that women
do not desire men with a very high
uh sexual history in a sense and you
know there's good reasons for that even
in a short-term mating context you know
why are women more averse to short-term
mating one reason we know women have
higher disgust sensitivity than men do
as a sex difference disgust sensitivity
a fear or disgust uh aversion to
pathogens we know that women can
contract STDs or STI more easily than
men can and that sort of a thing so
every sexual partner a woman has is a
risk uh of exposure to disease in that
sense so a highly promiscuous man okay
at the same time every sexual encounter
a woman has even if it's shortterm also
represents a risk of I guess a lack of
resource a risk of pregnancy a lack of
investment so it's kind of like if this
is someone that's having sex with a lot
of people and I get pregnant how willing
are they to invest in me and I don't
think that's a explicit cognition that
women have that would be something under
the surface in a sense you know from The
evolutionary perspective but yeah
there's a lot that signals you know and
and I think as well aside you know we we
kind of draw this line short and
long-term mating but I don't think it's
entirely clear that people always
perceive of their short-term mating as
simply unre you know strictly casual sex
a lot of short-term mating especially in
actual behavior is kind of the jump off
point to long-term mating you know you
have a one night stand is it because you
intended to have a one night stand or is
it because you liked the guy and you
wanted to continue dating and then he
ghosted you you know or whatever the
case may be so or or the same with like
situationships and all of that people
start you know saying well we're g to
have sex every once in a while but what
are we down the line six months you find
both people have fallen in love and now
they're in a relationship so it's not
always the case that you know there's a
clear line between long and short-term
and actual Behavior yeah so just to
reiterate those six main red flags gross
clingy addicted promiscuous apathetic
and unmotivated and before I read the
results I tried to think what would be
the highest what will be the the the big
biggest red flag for men and for women
and I thought for women it would be
gross largely because of the disgust
sensitivity but the the highest rated
one was clinginess that that's the
biggest red flag for women what why do
you think that's the case what does that
say about women and why the [__] is no
one talking about this on the
internet I'm not entirely sure why
clinginess would be the highest one but
I think something in kind of the mating
psychology of women is that they do want
a man who they can depend upon and not
someone that they have to be a mommy to
in a sense you know so if it's the sense
that you know this is someone who's not
independent who's not emotionally stable
or strong that you can lean upon that
could be a big red flag to women in that
sense clinginess could also represent a
a threat kind of like a stalker as well
someone who's very clingy and all of
that like you know uh could they behave
in a way that's emotionally volatile and
perhaps hurt me but not entirely sure
these are just kind of guesses that come
to my mind I read uh models by Mark
Manson which is probably 10 years old
now so most people will know Mark for
subtle art of not giving a [__] really
great book but he actually wrote a I
guess you call it kind of like ethical
pickup Artistry book toward the back end
of the Neil Strauss hero in
20134 uh and he identifies the I this
study wasn't out maybe he read some
stuff but it seems to just be like field
tested advice
uh and he he called it something
different he called it neediness not
clinginess but I think that the
sentiment is the same and he just drills
up the one lesson that everybody that
reads models takes away is that
neediness is the number one Turner for
women and for guys can't be too needy
one of the or a few of the things that I
reflected on after reading that
were over o being overly pliable as a
man is a signal of low status that if if
you can it's why that you know the simps
never get the girl as a meme right the
simps sing for women is a ineffective
mating strategy because what it suggests
first off is that you have no other
options if you did H if you were
spending eight hours a day messaging me
I know that you're not spending 8 hours
a day messaging some other girl as well
unless you've got a really good AI bot
assisting you uh secondly it suggests a
a low bar a low
um a very low standard to the point
where it's probably a concern that
somebody else some other woman could
come in and quite easily slipstream this
exact same low level of self-esteem from
you so your level of dedication to me is
going to be less and then finally I
guess there's just some Brute Force
playground logic that I want the thing
that other people want right I don't
necessarily want it when I can play with
it and whenever it's available to be
played with me I want the thing that's a
little bit more sort of mysterious and
aloof and it's a little bit more
difficult to get so that's my
three-pronged bro science theory about
clinginess yeah I think so and these are
kind of deal breakers or red flags in
early relationship formation as well so
that can signal something very different
from down the line so let's say we have
someone who is very uh invested in the
relationship but it's really really
early and then you might have kind of a
in congruent signal like why is this
person uh already so attached to me
we've only been speaking for one week
but if you look at a married couple and
you say okay they text a lot or
something like that then it's kind of
like oh that you know that might
actually be more desirable that might
more like commitment than need yeah yeah
women seem to really want commitment and
investment and attention and time but
somehow at the beginning of a
relationship that can signal kind of uh
the it can be the opposite of what is
attractive and then later on down the
line it can be kind of more appropriate
in that sense yeah what about uh you
talking about marriage and some of the
stuff that's going on uh alpacino is he
who's the guy there some Hollywood
celebrity that's just got into another
massive age Gap relationship I can't
remember who one of those like kind of
old Legend actors what do you think is
the reason for age Gap
taboos so one idea that I had was
intersexual competition right the idea
that you know if you have a mating pool
it's going to be people similar to your
own age so or a mating pool of mates
that are more desirable that have more
res resources or something along those
lines so it could be the case that when
people see an age Gap relationship they
are thinking you know uh this is someone
being pulled from my mating pool in a
sense by someone outside of that range
if that were the case we might see age
differences between men and women in age
Gap uh taboos so I looked at that but I
didn't find an age difference for women
women seem to approve or disapprove of
age gaps about the same across the board
so sometimes we get that discourse that
says you know it's old women that are
jealous of young women or sometimes you
uh say hear people say no it's young
women that disapprove more because you
know old people are gross or whatever
the case may be but it doesn't seem that
there's an age uh difference like that
for women but for men there was so young
men disapproved of age gaps more than
older men which maybe does is kind of
congruent with that self-interest
perspective or with intersexual
competition but rather than in men it
would be in women in that case because
if young men see you know age gaps is
pulling women from their dating pool and
women do already date up in age they
might be more threatened by that they
might say yeah age gaps are
inappropriate why well because they're
stealing the women from you basically in
a sense you know and I've even heard
people argue that explicitly they said
you know serial monogamy and age gaps
are stealing the young women and that's
why young men are are are single or
something like that so that could be one
thing but I don't think that explains
all of the taboo I think a lot of it is
kind of cultural you you you have kind
of a narrative of power imbalances but
at the same time you know I looked at
hierarchical relationships where there
might be a power imbalance you know
someone a boss an employee that doesn't
seem to have as much of an effect as age
gaps either so you know that's kind of
one explanation you often see from
feminists this idea that you know
there's a big Power imbalance in age
gaps there probably often isn't and
people don't seem to disapprove as much
of power imbalances when the age is
close so it seems to be the case that
there is this taboo that's not entirely
explained and I think it might just come
down to kind of kind of an ick in a
sense for some people and that's kind of
you know a feeling that people have is
just kind of a a visceral revulsion and
I think why that might occur is when
people think of dating someone who is
much older they just simply think from
their own experience I'm not attracted
to much older people I could not imagine
dating alpacino you know a woman who's
20 she alpacino look at him that's gross
and that's all it comes down to a lot of
taboos can simply emerge from that
visceral feeling like yuck and then the
rationalizations come in is because of
lack of consent or a power imbalance or
somebody that's being manipulative with
their wealth or their status or whatever
it might be exactly yeah people that's
what happens a lot of the time we
experience emotions first and then we
come up with explanations for those
emotions and I think that can be what
happens when people feel that visceral
ick you know you know they they think e
gross and yeah then they come up with
rationalizations to explain why it's
gross maybe those aren't the real
reasons you know but that's what they
felt in the moment and and that's how
they feel now interestingly something I
found there was people who had had age
Gap relationships of course they were
more approving of age gaps so because I
see some discourse on that as well that
says you know a lot of people have had
an age Gap relationship a lot of women
true and they said you know they learned
from their bad experiences and if that
were the case you would expect people
that had age Gap relationship to
disapprove but it was the opposite so it
doesn't even seem to be the case that
they're driven by like bad experiences
you know those people actually seem to
support them more interesting what you
said about how uh women dating older
creates a death of potential female
partners for younger men because the
younger women are captured by slightly
older
men I I there's not really a way to
bestow this wisdom onto younger men but
like one day in a couple of years time
you will be those older men I it it
seems I I totally get it like you know
if if you're a guy who's 22 and all of
the girls are getting flown out to God
knows where by 38y olds like yeah that's
that's going to suck but ultimately it's
just like a like a diluted
gerontocracy
right yeah exactly and that's kind of
related you know we have like the Pew
statistics that say you know like 60% of
men are single between 20 and 30 and you
know 30% of women are single why is that
are they sharing the men what's going on
a lot of that Gap can actually be
explained simply by women dating outside
of that age range on average so for the
and and it's much more pronounced among
you know 18 to 25 than it is even among
25 to 30 so it seems to be the case that
it's a real effect if you're a man who's
like 18 to 23 or something like that you
know a lot of those women that you could
otherwise date they're going to be
dating dating up you're 18 now so you're
probably not going to date down you know
which is what the older men are doing so
you do kind of see it balance out down
the line but it does kind of create a a
singles Gap especially for like really
really young men and I think you know I
don't know if that's always super
obvious looking at the landscape or if
they think you know the women are
sharing like the same Chad who's in
their class that's the same age but a
lot of that yeah is just women dating up
a little bit and there's you know the
average age Gap is not huge it's you
know two to four years or something like
that
but a lot of people are dating outside
of the average and when you total all of
those up you know you get something like
around 20% of women who are between 18
and 30 we're dating men older so that
yeah already pulls a big big chunk of
women
out yeah I I love the less
conspiratorial uh explanations for this
stuff that's one of the reasons that I
really like your work man like for all
that we both get accused of being blue
blue blue pilled cooks or or misogynist
bigots depending on who it is that's
that's looking at what we've written or
said um you know it's like it's just a
calming pretty well balanced nice gentle
look at what does the data say what do
we know about human psychology how can
we marry these two together isn't that
interesting the world's probably not
quite as [__] as you think it is like
it's just it's a very peaceful way to
look at what is quite a chaotic world I
think yeah exactly it's human psychology
very complex so many variables so you
always have to have a very nuanced
perspective it's rarely just as simple
as X Y and Z there's always so many
different things going on and if people
can calm down a little bit look at the
big picture and you know be a little bit
stoic about it if if they're in a
difficult situation it's not always you
know roses but it's usually not the full
black pill either in that sense what are
you researching next what can people
expect from you so right now we're
looking at some data on only fans on
attitudes about only fans and only fans
workers and this is just going to be
some descriptive data this is looking at
uh because this seems to be a topic that
actually people might be afraid to
explore in the research a little bit
because they're afraid that it's kind of
stigmatizing but at the same time people
do seem to have you know overwhelmingly
negative attitudes about this and and as
far as impacts of only fans on future uh
relationship prospects will someone date
an only fans worker will this hurt their
future job offerings and also related to
that what kind of political attitudes or
beliefs might predict support for that
kind of work or the opposite of of
support for that kind of work very so
you are delving deep into the archives
of only fans is that what I'm hearing
yeah that's what we're looking at now
we're looking at attitudes about it I
can't believe you finally managed to get
your Recreation and your work to to come
together appropriately Alex I I these
episodes dude I look at the clock and
it's been an hour and 40 minutes and it
feels like it's been five I really
appreciate the time I get to spend with
you uh where should people go they want
to keep up to date with all of the
things you're doing sure so we got the
website dates psychology.com on Twitter
at daty and YouTube alex. daty thank you
man catch you next time thank you if you
enjoyed that episode then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to
[Music]
subscribe